let's talk about the best meal that you
could eat to help reduce plaquing in
your arteries or even help prevent
cardiovascular disease now I've done a
lot of videos on what to avoid to
prevent heart disease today I'm going to
primarily focus on what to eat okay but
we first have to give you a little
background of what is going on behind
the scenes as far as a cardiovascular
disease and primarily we're going to
talk about plaque now what is in plaque
plaque is a combination of calcium
protein and cholesterol many times the
calcium is the result of biofilms so
what's the biofilm it's a colony of
microbes that these microbes have built
these little calcium igloos or shells to
protect themselves so they can go
underneath the radar so when you see
calcium plaque in the arteries
underneath that plaquin there could be a
microbial community and biofilms 10 to
accumulate on roughened edges right if
the arteries were nice and smooth and
strong they probably would never
accumulate on the arteries but the
question is what causes them to get
stuck on the inside of the artery wall
and your coronary artery for example
well that would be some type of um they
call that lesion or oxidation or
inflammation or damage from you know
excessive sugar in the diet it could be
your diabetic you could be a
pre-diabetic it could come from omega-6
fatty acids junk Foods alcohol all sorts
of things so when you see plaquing
you're also going to see this LDL a very
specific kind the small dense particle
size and that's correlated too with a
high sugar high carb diet and some of
this cholesterol in this little package
and that's what the LDL is It's A
protein that carries cholesterol
cholesterol doesn't exist as cholesterol
in the arteries like free-floating it's
always in a little shuttle bus but the
cholesterol is coming in the form of
Band-Aid with this cement the the
calcium and then also you're going to
get a fibrous tissue like a protein seen
cement that kind of mixes in with the
calcium and the cholesterol as a
Band-Aid and then you'll see like um a
thrombus or a clot forming two in that
same area so given that information what
can we do to prevent slow down or
reverse this situation all right there's
several things to know about this um one
of the controlling vitamins with calcium
is vitamin K2 vitamin K2 drives the
calcium into the bone without enough K2
calcium tends to develop in the soft
tissues of the body not just your
arteries but also in the joints as well
and there's one more point about
biofilms there's some interesting things
about biofilms especially when we're
dealing with plaquing in your arteries
there's several studies that I found
that links periodontal
bacteria the bacteria in your mouth this
pathogenic bacteria actually ending up
in the plaquing in your arteries I mean
that's interesting because what are
these uh peridontal
bacteria they're pathogenic they're in
your mouth doing in your heart okay now
you have to realize like in the mouth
you have over 700 different species okay
not just bacteria but different types of
bacteria in your mouth and one of the
reasons why the bacteria can actually go
through the pores uh through your gums
and into your bloodstream is the same
reason why bacteria can leak from your
intestines into your bloodstream that's
called bacterial translocation where
bacteria is moving through the wall
because there's increased leakiness or
permeability and a lot of times that
leakiness comes from a vitamin C
deficiency and this is why when people
are deficient vitamin C they might get
bleeding gums so that allows the
microbes to go right through these
little holes into your bloodstream so
high vitamin C foods are definitely
necessary for this meal so foods with
large amounts of vitamin C would also be
a good thing then we have vitamin E okay
vitamin E in relationship to keeping
your cardiovascular system intact is
very very important first of all it
helps prevent those lesions on the
inside of the um the wall of the artery
called endothelial tissue when you're
low in vitamin E which is a very
powerful antioxidant you can get a lot
of oxidation and inflammation so vitamin
E is very important and also it's
important in the heart muscle itself
keeping your oxygen high and preventing
an actual heart attack so we have
vitamin K2 very important vitamin C very
important and vitamin E and the other
important thing with the heart
especially to avoid that lesion in the
artery is to keep your omega-6 fatty
acids very low and keep your omega-3
very very high so a really important
thing in this meal should be omega-3
fatty acids okay all right so what
should this Meal look like well let's
start from the top
omega-3 fatty acids okay what food is
very very high in omega-3 and that would
be wild caught salmon so if you include
salmon in this meal okay you're going to
have a good amount of omega-3 fatty
acids which is going to support the
arteries as well as the heart muscle
itself and having enough omega-3 will
decrease your inflammation as well in
your artery series and doing that can
actually lower blood pressure as well
all right there's something else that I
think is very very important in
preventing and even maybe reversing some
of this plaquing in the arteries this
thing has like seven times the
requirements of vitamin C it also is one
of the most microbial dense foods that
you can eat giving you a strong
probiotic effect with high levels of
lactic acid bacterium now let me just
kind of discuss lactic acid bacteria
it's not just one bacteria it's a group
of many different types of bacteria that
is usually involved in fermentation and
so the food that I'm talking about is
sauerkraut okay that is a fermented
cabbage product and sauerkraut is loaded
with this lactic acid bacteria and
lactic acid bacteria as a standalone
thing is very interesting because it can
act as an Ace inhibitor to help lower
blood pressure it can inhibit bio films
which is very very cool it can decrease
the risk of cardiovascular disease by
supporting your gut there is a huge
relationship between a healthy gut
with the right microbes and a healthy
heart also this lactic acid bacteria can
help regulate LDL cholesterol especially
the small dense particle size LDL and
having enough of this lactic acid
bacteria can enhance your production of
secondary biosaults which can help the
absorption of more vitamin E
vitamin d and vitamin K2 all three of
those are fat soluble and can greatly
support the cardiovascular tissue and it
just so happens the sauerkraut is loaded
with vitamin K2 now normally vitamin K2
is in like certain hard cheeses fats but
microbes can also make k2 just to
summarize what sauerkraut is it's a
superfood for the heart it supports the
gut lining to prevent this these
microbes from traveling through a leaky
gut up into the heart it has many
different diverse types of microbial
entities that can greatly help you in
many different ways and then sauerkrauts
loaded with vitamin K2 to keep the
calcium out of the arteries it's loaded
with vitamin C like I said before seven
times the RDA so that gives you a
tremendous amount of vitamin C that can
directly inhibit biofilms as well as act
as an antioxidant in your arteries
preventing these lesions or damage to
the wall of the arteries remember the
biofilms can only stick to an area
that's roughened or irritated so if your
arteries are smooth they can't quite
stick to the inside of your arteries to
form the plaquing in the first place and
the last part of this meal is a big
arugula salad with several things in it
which I'm going to cover but arugula as
a vegetable is a superior salad green
compared to regular lettuce because
first of all it's cruciferous so it's
really good for the liver it's bitter it
has blood glucose lowering properties
it's loaded with something called dim
which can help lower biofilms directly
it also has fiber the feed the bacteria
and it's also loaded in potassium which
can help keep the arteries softened so
your blood pressure can stay normal and
then of course on that salad I would put
extra virgin olive oil the real stuff it
has significant effect effects on blood
pressure not to mention it has a very
powerful anti-inflammatory effects as
well then it would also add apple cider
vinegar but you can also use balsamic
vinegar red but the acetic acid in the
vinegar has many properties to help
lowering the risk of cardiovascular
disease it's great for helping regulate
your blood sugar it can help regulate
your cholesterol it can help mobilize
your bile salts and it has
anti-inflammatory properties and then if
you add sunflower seeds okay we can
Spike more vitamin E and like I said
before vitamin E is very very important
now the next thing I want to talk about
is a hard cheese okay hard cheeses are
loaded with vitamin K2 and the type of
cheese I would recommend is called
parmigiano now I probably do not
pronounce that exactly like I should but
the American translation from Italian is
parmesan but apparently there's been a
lot of lawsuits involving this topic
because apparently craft trademarked
this English translation from the real
parmesan cheese in Italy because the
real parmigiano version of that cheese
is only produced by a collective group
of farmers in Northern Italy
that keep their standards very very high
and this has been going on since the
Middle Ages it wasn't until only fairly
recently that craft came in there and
started to make it but unfortunately
there's a big difference in how they
make it in America versus how they make
it in Italy in Italy they age it for
like one to three years compared to in
America I think they age it for 10
months and the crafts version of this
cheese definitely does not have to abide
by the same policies and rules and laws
then the authentic cheese in Italy has
to abide by and the other thing you have
to watch out for in this Americanized
parmesan cheese is that sometimes they
add this filler of cellulose okay which
is wood pulp so what I would recommend
is get the authentic type from Italy and
shave it on your salad I do it every
single day that way you have a delicious
cheese that's loaded with vitamin K2 and
it's great amount of protein there's
probiotics in this product and it's an
incredible product I actually went to
one of the Farms where they create this
cheese and I was blown away at what they
feed the cows to make sure the microbes
are just right and the soils that they
grow the grass on for the cows they
don't get fed grain it's all grass and
the amount of work that goes in to make
this cheese and keep it a really
standard process
is mind-blowing and the last thing I'm
going to recommend to put on your salad
is garlic okay you can use powder you
can use actual garlic you can use
fermented garlic but garlic is great for
the heart it actually can thin the blood
if there's a chance that you are high
risk for clotting it can help lower your
blood pressure it's antimicrobial
anti-biofilm and the list goes on and on
all right so now that you have that
information I think the best most
interesting next video for you to watch
would be the one on biofilms in your
mouth check it out I put it right here